thank you
[Music]
who here is a fan I feel like I've asked
this before of Mr Tom Hardy
also just did a jiu jitsu match and won
crazy this guy literally just won a jiu
jitsu competition he's Bane bro and
apparently he was [ __ ] everyone up
well how long has he been training
dude you ever seen him in that movie the
MMA movie What's called the Warriors
that actual good movie it's actually a
good game but yeah he's like he does
like MMA stuff in that movie because
he's a fight he plays a fighter in it
and he's like very believable as MMA
fighter he's he's been trained for that
that's not the one wait wait don't say
it okay it's not Christian Bale one it's
the other one with the other dude who is
a really good actor but for some reason
I don't like him
um yeah you hate that guy yeah you like
you loved it you love to not like him he
was that movie with Jason Bateman where
he's like a little weirdo yes it's a
gift of that movie yeah exactly yeah
that guy we don't know anything who's
this guy oh look at him the rest of us
cannot like him he's with Nick Nolte
movie his name is Joel Edgerton yes yeah
yeah yeah Edgerton why don't you like
him he's a good actor but for some
reason it's you don't uh connect to him
uh maybe he's always playing the role
that's like the bad one just off of the
the hero he's the most normal white
looking dude you've ever seen oh you
know he's like not never the villain
he's almost like but he's not the
protagonist he's like a complication in
the protagonist and the Will Smith see
what you mean he was like his partner
right but the alien partner or whatever
oh he's the wait wait the orc movie
where the cops he's the orc yeah he's
the orc oh [ __ ] oh he's the ore yeah
yeah it's him huh yeah oh I didn't know
that was him well I guess we lost Joe
dude he's not into this at all I was
showing him a picture of the dude yeah
yeah Edgar tell her that is Joel
Edgerton Edgerton Edgerton I'm not going
names I don't know I didn't ever knew
his name well there it is Joel see you
didn't like him either then point is
which uh which which tournament or a
competition was this at was it like at a
pretty big one so uh this was uh blah
blah blah re-org r-e-o-r-g open Jiu
Jitsu championship at uh aldersley
Leisure Village uh on Saturday August
20th wait so he rolled a bunch of senior
citizens it sounds like a retirement
time it's like I'm the Leisure World
Champion dang I don't know but if that's
what it is and maybe he he is 44. be in
the Masters division yeah
young or old for fighter that's pretty
old yeah geriatric division yeah yeah I
mean I heard the word leisure in there
so I was like Leisure World Leisure
Village
is a good year for our fighters to
retire because that's when I'll start
[ __ ] [ __ ] up in the 40s I think you
peak in your 30s all right cool and then
you you're done in your 40s cool I'm
gonna wait till you you just wait 45
year olds or get you they have that age
division
you could be at any age really
especially in Jiu Jitsu boxing too and
mutak doesn't match up yeah we have 45
55 year olds fighting everybody can
fight is there like a different
Insurance liability on those or I think
Idris Alba did his first pro fight at 40
something
yeah yeah but he's like I really want to
do it so he like trained for he's
fighting lions in his last movie he just
does not look like he's 25. he looks
like he's 35. Idris Elba yeah that guy
looks like an old dude yeah she's
heimdell
black don't crack though you know yeah
that's my point really well so um in
addition to proving his skills in the
sport Tom Hardy is also a trustee of the
reord charity which teaches those with
life-altering injuries or those who are
suffering from PTSD and depression uh
the art of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
oh that's that's nice I like using
martial arts as a way for mental health
and then this weekend's championships
that he just won the profits of which
went straight to the good cause Saul
Hardy steal the show and not just
because of his Hollywood status
he actually just [ __ ] fools up I
watched one of the I watched I watched
one of the the matches and then he gets
a guy in an arm bar but you can tell
like the guy really didn't want to get
in one and then I was like I don't know
if it was
he didn't want to get armed Bart he just
don't want to get armbarred by Tom Hardy
wait what does that mean when you say he
didn't want to get in because like you
know what it's like someone has you in
an arm bar show him no no you you are
someone has them in a at an arm bar look
at that technique like um this guy he's
fighting he doesn't want it he doesn't
want to get tapped out but then I I
couldn't tell if this guy was more
physically resisting or because of the
shame yeah because
I'm gonna clown them all day but if
there's anyone a celebrity to get
armbarred by it's [ __ ] Tom Hardy bro
you know like I feel like he's a cool
celebrity if I was getting armed by like
let's say
yeah [ __ ] Rick Moranis dude I'd be
bummed Miranda is that what you just
said
I don't want to get armbarred by him who
would you want to get armed Barbed by
no somebody like the rock because you're
like well it's the rock bro or like if
it's like so you don't want to get I'm
gonna be like Jason Jack Bauer dude I
can get our bar by Jack Bauer I'm in
anyone that's believable Jada Pinkett
Smith yeah she's believable she was
Nairobi dude anybody that's believable I
think oh snap Florence cute
yeah dude
could be cool
if he's a [ __ ] black widow or
whatever she did wrestling movies right
yeah oh [ __ ] okay let me think of
somebody else
um so who's like a lame celebrity you'd
want to get beat up by or known to get
Michael Sarah Michael Sarah is a good
one but he's still likable but he Taps
you out you're like oh [ __ ] I got beat
up by super bad dude but I make love
what if he is
everybody wants to get their own part by
him he like armed by your pinky hanging
on for your life you just start randomly
attacking you during interviews there's
a bunch of celebs that are like
undercover badasses like who like Mario
Lopez
regularly and I've also heard he
actually does a lot of amateur boxing he
could like like his actual boxing record
is pretty good is it Russell Peters uh
black belt or some [ __ ] in Jiu Jitsu
yeah Purple belt or something
so many Jiu Jitsu lovers didn't know
that why are they like closet lovers why
why are these things they don't promote
it'll be famous for everything else yeah
yeah like Keanu Reeves I think he got
like I think he has some belts too I
think he's like he probably has so many
accolades that like just like on the
bottom of his list you know he's
probably like you know like freaking
ranked number one in Pokemon go
because people that are talented that's
a sick ass break can you imagine ranked
number one yeah number one he's the gym
you know like when people are talented
they're hella talented in so many
different things
yeah I hate those people yeah like Ryan
yeah Ryan oh Ryan's talented in so many
things yeah but I'm also you know a
[ __ ] guy and what happened but
that's cool everybody else is here
you're in the right place man oh dude
while I'm making [ __ ] knife nunchucks
with my ass dude see this [ __ ] that's
like did he just make a weapon this is
our medial side I could also assume
though like um because right now we're
talking about like a lot of people who
are in like the entertainment industry
right you're just you're Tom Hardy's or
Keanu Reeves who are also oftentimes put
in like action or War films or fighting
movies so you have to already get
trained for that role like I could
that's the Gateway like yeah getting
trained and then being like yo this is
sick as [ __ ] like imagine you get cast
for a superhero movie so you have to
learn how to fight some [ __ ] and you get
put through the the training rear and
suddenly you're like most fit you've
ever been you're like I'm down to do
this a little bit the difference is
though uh getting trained versus going
out and competing is like a different
world that's what I'm saying like
Gateway though like just the fact that
you're exposed to it at like a
professional level in an environment
that's probably uh prioritizing your
experience and safety it must be such a
sick gateway to like get into the things
well that's the thing I think it it does
take getting over that hump because it's
it would be the same if like Michael B
Jordan got trained to do all the boxing
movies right and then now he actually
competes in boxing and when you're
actually going out there not to make
film but someone's trying to beat your
ass it's a way different and they know
you're Michael B Jordan yeah and they
want to take their ass up yeah I I don't
doubt that I'm thinking about like I
remember watching the behind the scenes
of Lord of the Rings one time and uh
Viggo Mortensen right our Aragorn guy
very nerdy [ __ ] I remember he [ __ ]
was able he had to ride horses for the
movie and then he was like [ __ ] love
riding horses so every day on his day
off you're just [ __ ] ride he plays
Polo yeah and I'll be like yo that must
be sick as [ __ ] imagine like any type of
movie worth even like a war movie right
and you just gotta [ __ ] [ __ ] with
guns all day or some [ __ ] like that
there's Karen tactical guys like you see
all those celebrities go over there
those guys can't shoot like they I don't
I don't know anything about shooting
guns but in my eyes I'm like they they
look like and maybe again if they're in
like war and [ __ ] maybe they'll piss and
[ __ ] themselves for sure but the idea
that you've been trained to be able to
like one use the weapon and be fairly
good enough to charge that weapon
discharge that weapon that's not a
badass yeah you get paid and trained by
the best yeah that's true I said Alec
Baldwin then some [ __ ]
yeah dude but I feel like any high level
actor truly becomes their role right
like they have to like truly like eat
sleep and breathe it so become the
rapist yeah yeah right so you're gonna
be a rapist like
this like no everything that the
mentality like the the train of thought
and whatnot you have to believe yeah
what's what's your most favorite and or
authentic or doesn't matter but fight
movie fight movie
enough or take it take it Save the Last
Dance is that a fight movie no that's a
kidnapping movie yeah you know to be
honest all Rambo I'll fight MMA fight
movies are all a little on the tacky
side yeah yeah I haven't seen one where
I was like oh dang that was just a good
movie because there's a good movie that
makes sense that's like us watching
Dance movies like we're all kind of
funny to us yeah they all most of them
suck what about the mark de Costa's
movie where he does capoeira Only the
Strong yeah that [ __ ] is fine but what
about like uh [ __ ] what's that movie oh
the creep have you ever seen Creed yeah
what do you think about those movies
boxing movies are so different boxing
yeah boxing has been around so long
that's kind of It kind of you can kind
of create a story because people have
been making movies been making movies
forever and they choose boxing because
there's so much History unit but MMA the
history is not that long that's true
yeah 25 years now which seems like a lot
is to say that to Donnie Yen and
everybody who reps Chinese kung fu in
the modern Western World you know like
that dude you're making a movie about
something centuries in the making you
know there's a lot of backstory you can
put with MMA it's always oh it's the
it's the rags the richest Stories the
dude that had a heart and he's going
through a hard time and now he either
made it or he did it or and he has PTSD
now yeah yeah yeah he has a rough life
you know it's a karate movie where
everyone's like that [ __ ] don't work and
he's like I know but I still want to
keep it going
because Karate Kid is like one of my
favorite [ __ ] films that movie's fire
bro ever yeah Karate Kid's crazy you
know what I I also think like growing up
in Southern California and watching the
movies that took place here yeah yeah so
it's like the locations and everything
all Valley Karate Championship it just
feels like it's a part of the
neighborhood the best part in a Karate
Kid where he's like come on yeah
it really made me feel like bullies were
gonna roundhouse me
have you seen a spin-offs where the
freaking Karate Kid is actually the
bully yeah yeah it's like dang that's
actually when you really look at it it's
like dude he [ __ ] everything up that's
why you gotta watch Cobra Kai because
they built it off of that fan video
watched the whole two seasons come on
every single season except for the two
out of the three well that's why Daniel
sound becomes the bully too yeah he's
the bad guy it's great man
foreign
[Music]